[Music]
for us to count a machine ultimately as
a as a real as a real person we'd want
it to have its own subjectivity and its
own Consciousness are we going to
um make machines Tools in our image or
are we going to worship the machines and
try to make ourselves in the image of
the machines the fashion is that no no
we're going to build a machine and and
human consciousness is essentially we
will be able to capture it in a digital
machine yeah well I think that's just
wrong to properly understand
intelligence
you you need to root it in its
biological context AI systems and AI
research model human thoughts but not
human thinking first we see wearables
and later it evolves into you know AI
actually inside of the head in every
Arena
that we have thought is
uniquely human they will transcend us
the question for us to entertain is why
should we fear Ai and that is just going
to be a a entryway a vector into a
serious Corruption of our justice system
foreign
[Music]
the question for us to entertain is why
should we fear AI we're building
programs that do remarkable things but
certainly not in the way that we do
question we discussed on a pound this
morning was well will they just keep
evolving faster than we can and just
become suddenly super bright we have no
reason to think so it's very hard to
know what the general uh intelligence
that we have certainly self-reflective
intelligence is about
but they will become extraordinarily
capable in these Niche tasks and it will
be for us to decide what to do with
those uh those capabilities will they
for example take all our jobs well
they're going to be in taking all our
jobs according to the Spiegel for the
last 50 years this is a front cover in
64 78 and 2016. you know
two things about that yes automation
will dislocate people out of some jobs
but we humans are very ingenious about
giving ourselves new things to do about
valuing things that we want humans to do
and inventing whole new classes of
activity for us to be paid for from game
show host to uh to organize us as an AI
festivals
this is the thing we should be slightly
more concerned about it's the strangers
we've invited into our home
Alexa it's what will happen when we put
more and more AI into the toys that our
children play with
it's the platforms that control all the
data
these are immediate and pressing
challenges that have to do as much with
governance they have to do as much with
um the whole challenge around
who determines what ends this technology
is put to
now Computing and AI is a dual use
technology just as the chemical science
biological science and nuclear science
has been used for what we might think of
as constructive and rather more
destructive purposes
we shouldn't be giving up on this just
because it seems like it's rampaging
ahead we have to exactly now begin to
think about what the limitation treaties
are what the
um self-ordinance challenges are whether
we can put some of the rules of the road
into the programs themselves not they're
aware of it but they effectively
Implement Rules of Engagement that will
prove to be tricky but we will need to
do it
we will need
more urgently to work out who's got our
data and who's doing what with it
because all of these AI algorithms
particularly the later generations are
rapacious and very hungry when it comes
to consuming data and I will just leave
you with a slight frightener because uh
um this is uh
this is fun
those of you who have your apps on your
smartphone whether it's an iPhone or an
Android
um
this is one app Airbnb a lot of you
might be using it
if you have Airbnb with eBay and
Instagram and Tinder say those four apps
you've got a lot more than four apps on
your phone this is the flow of
information off that one app about where
you are your personal details your phone
characteristics your phone idea your
general location your exact location
these are all the places that Hoover it
up
and this is what it's being used for
did you know that flow of data do you
think you're in control of it are The
Regulators allowing you to be in control
of it
um what does the future look like in
which
we are somewhat more in control of this
evolving landscape and what's true for
data will be true for the AI algorithms
themselves what we mustn't do is allow
professors of AI or Geeks in basements
or the 15 or so middle-aged super rich
white blokes in Silicon Valley to make
decisions on our behalf about how and
when and where all of this technology
should be used I'm huge admirer of the
products of these companies in many
respects but that doesn't mean
they are given a free reign and you're
starting to see a little bit of a
pushback on that very issue as we speak
I mean is it possible that AI does
acquire associate at least between other
artificial intelligence machines if not
between AI machines and humans okay so
here we go again with the uh the the
idea about acquiring is really
interesting because as I just said it's
designed right so even if a system
changes over time because it's got
machine learning built into it now in
real life
the machine learning usually is used
during the development phase as an end
is no longer used in production so when
you get to play with the AI it's not
actually learning except and very
carefully specified ways like you can
learn your name it might be maybe it can
learn the layout of your house if it's a
vacuum cleaner most of these Robot
vacuum cleaners don't learn the layout
of your house they just bump around
right but even if you had that even if
you as a company sat down and said I'm
going to produce this product that
really is going to develop and change
that is still the responsibility of the
corporation so that okay so that was
about well AI itself acquire yeah when
we design that you think yeah so now the
question but so morally that changes a
lot we may design it that way
um and I think what's worse is that um
people may choose to Market it in such a
way that is human legal personality even
though it is actually an extension of a
corporation or a government or some
other powerful individual right so uh
it's literally buying votes right
there's this idea there's again complete
disinformation that Sophia the robot is
a citizen of Saudi Arabia was never true
um it was made a uh honorary citizen I
mean there are so many constraints about
being a citizen of Saudi Arabia that
Sophia the robot doesn't make you have
to be at least Muslim but it's not
sufficient to be Muslim but you have to
at least be Muslim to be a citizen of
Saudi Arabia right so the um
there's a yeah there's a lot of fictions
that are and disinformation spread and
so what I'm worried about is there may
very well be artificial intelligence
that is given uh uh these kinds of legal
powers and that is just going to be a a
entryway a vector into a serious
Corruption of our justice system so why
we'll get to the ethical questions in a
bit but why do you think there is so
much misunderstanding around AI you've
touched upon A1 the metaphor of
anthropomorphizing machines and and be
the sort of like marketing side from
from companies that are developing AI
what do you are those the main sources
of misunderstanding no I actually I
don't think so although they of course
marketers are very well motivated to try
to make themselves uh but but I do think
it's fundamental to how we socialize
that whenever we meet an entity that we
think might be human uh then we start uh
playing sort of in-group out group games
we say you know do you speak English
things like that and try to to figure
out can if if you're a teenager you say
what's your favorite band you know you
immediately try to figure out how much
can I trust this entity and so I think
when people are encounter technology
with which they can speak of course
they're going to play those games so of
course they're going to see and they but
but it all breaks down so the human the
fact that I'm spending this time talking
to you really is an honest signal that
that I somehow valued the time we have
together and that we have something in
common but with a machine of course it
doesn't matter how long it spends
talking to you so the person may feel
confident because the machine spent a
lot of time at the beginning uh you know
chatting about the weather or whatever
but in fact it's only costs a tiny
amount of electricity you know and to
the corporation or whatever that that's
uh that that that's providing that that
facility
I think that AI systems
will become so brilliant so complicated
that uh
we will not be able to even understand
them they will write poetry
that no person could ever write have
deeper insights into Human Nature than
any psychologist has ever had
in every Arena
that we have thought is
uniquely human they will transcend us uh
and leave us in the dust no doubt I have
no doubt about that we're stuck with 86
billion neurons they're not stuck
without limitation so the the best
poetry the best art the best movie
scripts the best insights into human
nature in the future will come from from
AIS and and we have to get used to that
do I think that they're conscious
yeah I think again I don't want to
accept the premise of that that question
I think the distinction that we make
between living and non-living things is
not a principle distinction
it's an artifact
of the limitations of our space-time
user interface so space and time our
perceptions are not
a perception of reality as it is it's a
headset
we've evolved a headset of you know four
dimensions the three dimensions of space
one dimension of time with physical
objects and a headset a user interface
necessarily is simplifying certain
things it gives you good insights into
some some parts of the reality outside
and it simplifies other things
so if Consciousness is fundamental
and space-time is just a headset
then
I'm always
without exception interacting with
Consciousness no matter what I do when I
pick up a spoon when I drink a cup of
coffee I'm always interacting with
Consciousness but my my user interface
is dumbing things down so I I don't ever
see
all the time the Consciousness behind
when I when I talk with Bernardo I'm
just seeing skin hair and eyes but but
that symbol in my interface gives me
genuine insight into bernardo's
Consciousness and I can tell if he's
interested or if he disagrees I I get it
so my interface gives me a portal into
bernardo's Consciousness whereas when I
look at my cat my portal is not nearly
as good I have some insight into the
experience it likes tuna but it doesn't
like you know peanut butter so there I
have some insight into into when I when
I have a interface symbol that I call an
ant my inside is even less and at some
point when I get down to a rock my
insight is is is is gone and so but that
doesn't mean that
um I'm not interacting with
Consciousness when I see a rock it just
means that my interface gave up so so
for example right now on the screen I
see Kurt's face on on pixels on the
screen some of the pixels are just
pixels for a wall they're giving me no
insight into Consciousness but the
pixels that I see that are Kurt's face
are giving me some insight into Kurt's
conscious experiences does that mean
that some of the pixels on my screen are
conscious pixels and other pixels are
not conscious pixels no it's just that
some pixels provide a portal that's
useful into Kurt's conscious experiences
and other pixels do not so a rock
um is a set of pixels in my interface
that doesn't give me insight into the
Consciousness behind
but that doesn't mean that there's some
principal distinction between you know
unconscious rocks and and conscious
human brains that that distinction that
we make is mistaking a limit of our
interface for an insight into the nature
of reality it's a it's a rookie mistake
if I saw a machine exhibiting the kinds
of complex behavior that a human being
can exhibit I would probably attribute
thought and Consciousness to it but as
long as if you can just kind of reach
inside
as long as there's any simple brain scan
you can do of an animal or any simple
computer program you can do scale of a
computer and say Ah that's where the
thinking is are you therefore pursuing
official intelligence or artificial
Consciousness can you have one without
else well all these words are horribly
ambiguous I use Consciousness for the uh
for the subjective part I think it's
useful to use intelligence
for the behavioral part for the uh for
the operational part I mean just if
we're worried about machines taking over
the world then in a way what's going to
matter is the behavior
um if these machines are smart enough to
you know outsmart us and beat us in the
machine human war and so on it's going
to be a little consolation that they're
unconscious zombies right it's a it's
going to be intelligence and behavior
that makes the Practical difference so I
think it's at least useful for some
purposes to use intelligence for the uh
for the behavioral part and that does
allow you to bracket to some extent
questions about Consciousness well it
doesn't leave open the question how much
intelligent Behavior will you be able to
get from a system that doesn't have yeah
but you think we will get when you say
we'll get a
chieved cleverness you mean you will get
machines that are conscious like us so
we will make enough Consciousness I
believe that once we have machines which
are as intelligent as us can behave in
ways as sophisticated and impressive and
flexible as us they will also be
conscious I mean we don't understand
Consciousness so yeah it's all all
Consciousness is Magic somehow okay so I
think you've heard it here first yeah
the brain does it through complicated
information processing I think and
that's how that's how a computer will do
it too
[Music]
the biocentric notion of intelligence
was actually one that was popular
amongst philosophers prior to Descartes
who were influenced by Aristotle
on that old view what they called The
Soul was responsible for the vital
functions of the body
so there couldn't be a living system
unless there was literally some kind of
mental or Soulful activity at work
an innovation that we associate with
Descartes like kind of founding modern
science if you like it's part of this
rejection of Aristotelian philosophy and
this is demoting the soul from having
responsibility for keeping the body
alive
the body is now seen as a machine that
runs along without any need for
intelligence in its operations
so even the intelligent reactions of the
nervous system get reclassified as
simple reflexes and what you see on the
slides here is an image from one of
Descartes Publications where he's
showing the reflex which is
um enabling the man to withdraw his foot
so the reflexes to the part of the
nervous system here and then there is
this connection between the nerves of
the body and the Soul through the pineal
gland in the brain so the body and soul
do talk to each other
but the body's keeping itself alive is
just The Body Machine the soul doesn't
have to be involved with that
so if the body is just a machine and the
brain is just an organ of the body
responsible for intelligence and this is
what 20th and 21st century materialists
think or the people making AI devices
then it stands to reason that you could
instantiate intelligence in another kind
of machine such as a digital computer
and on this slide here you have Norbert
Fina who is one of the other founders of
AI so he was a part of this cybernetics
movement and what is pictured here is
one of his like cybernetic Creations
these were machines which were supposed
to have some kind of
self-regulating ability to sort of go
about their business in the world a bit
like an animal
but it was very much part of this
movement of research that whatever it is
that animals are doing is something that
could be quite straightforwardly
instantiated in a machine
and what he and his co-author are
talking about here
it's kind of admitting as when he says
that from the scientific standpoint the
methods of study of human and animal
behavior have to be applicable to
Mechanical objects as well I think what
he's admitting is that in order to make
sense of biological intelligence and
intelligent behavior of animals to make
sense of them as as a scientists they
have to think of them in machine-like
terms
so you don't get if you like the clarity
of scientific Insight that they want
into biological intelligence without
using machines as a model without
drawing some analogy between what people
have made these engineered devices and
what they think is going on in animals
as well but I emphasize this because
what I think it tells us is it's not a
discovery of science that
animals are machine-like it's that
science has to assume that animals are
machine-like in order to make sense of
them which is why this idea of machines
having all the properties of animals
seems then really compelling to people
I'm very very excited about the
possibility of AI going inside the head
um for example to help individuals who
have locked in syndrome or individuals
who can't move for other reasons but the
same Technologies
that may actually help individuals who
are radically disabled
um may also be the kind of Technologies
um that
pose dangers so I think again things
have to move forward very carefully
um so Elon Musk recently
um demoed the use of a brain chip uh in
pigs actually
and that technology as he noted is
incredibly transformative for
individuals who can't move
um wow right and and it's exciting that
it may be you know 10 years away from
development actual use that is
um or even five years away from actual
use but at the same time suppose that
normal people feel obligated to get
brain chips so that they can
um continue their jobs and keep up with
artificial intelligence to augment their
intelligence there I think we have to be
very careful because of the possibility
that we could have dystopian outcomes
now I want to argue that AI systems are
not actual thinkers and in that sense
they're not intelligent but thought
models so the nature of an AI system
is to be a model of the way in which
humans actually think and thereby also
the way in which humans are two things
so AI systems can surpass us in many
activities uh from more or less
Elementary pattern recognition in data
sets say up to skills that uh we very
much cherish such as chess playing or
playing go and other intellectual
activities certain mathematical proofs
and so forth so that is something that
seems to threaten human intelligence
because these systems to the extent to
which they model our intelligence
surpasses but on closer inspection a
thought model of course needn't be
intelligent in itself just like a model
of a city needn't be a city to be sure
many models share the relevant property
with the target system that their models
off so if I I flat a model of a city in
the Netherlands in order to predict
certain problematic outcomes of climate
warming and and catastrophic
catastrophic human-made climate change
if I do this then I do actually flood
something but I don't necessarily flood
a city because we don't build Dutch
cities in order to then flood them so
but that means that some models of
course share some interesting and
relevant property of their target system
whereas other models share less but or
rather more formal properties such as
the model of the Black Forest which
doesn't consist of trees but of certain
representations of trees whereas the
actual Black Forest consists of trees so
a Google map of the Black Forest which
helps me to find a restaurant in the
Black Forest that differs more from the
Black Forest in certain respects than a
model of a Dutch City differs from a
Dutch City with respect to flooding so
they're different types of relationships
between models and what their models are
their target systems now in the AI case
I think that AI systems and AI research
model human thoughts but not human
thinking so what their model is The
Logical structure
or some other mathematically accessible
structure that characterizes the
relationship between our thoughts but
what they don't model are the activities
of our thinking because the activities
of our thinking and that's going to be
crucial in a minute in the second part
are as a matter of fact in human animals
biologically grounded so no argument to
the effect that there could be or even
is conscious AI should of course assume
that we are conscious AIS in a relevant
sense there has to be a distinction
between us and the system whose
Consciousness we want to question and
and that difference lies in the other
element of the concept of AI namely in
the air in the a of the AI the
artificiality so AI systems other than
natural intelligent systems such as bees
and humans did not evolve in the way in
which we evolved we are cell-based life
forms highly complex and organized life
forms which are not even nearly
deciphered by the life and Natural
Sciences though we have made
considerable progress in particular over
the last 100 years or actually less
since the beginning of the discoveries
of molecular
genetics in particular but those
progresses of course all tell us that we
are essentially biologically grounded or
embodied as the saying goes alive well
tracked so you have to stick your
fitbits and sleep trackers and all the
technology that you can possibly afford
that is going to tell you how well
you're doing and it will give you
answers such as today you are 75 of what
is not clear
somehow your life experience can fit in
a line and
because it's data it has Authority so it
tells you who you are today and
I guess it encourages you through some
gamification problem process to be maybe
at 85 tomorrow
so this is the whole thing about
tracking and optimization this is a
major Silicon Valley philosophy of
um what you can't improve what you
cannot measure now apply to life it's a
little bit funny because most of the
important things in life you cannot
measure
so you end up measuring whatever you can
and then you optimize your life in that
direction
and I particularly like this one because
you know if you go for gamification you
might as well do it for everything so
you can have um streaks of how many days
in a row did you connect with God now
the thing is that it's worth
um looking a little bit more carefully
at where optimization comes from it's a
bit more than 100 years old and it
started with Taylor it's often referred
to as taylorism and what happened is
that with the Industrial Revolution when
you started having people working in
factories what you wanted to do is
actually having the interchangeable
workers so you wanted to um
box what everybody's tasks were and make
sure that they were as efficient as
possible and then optimize the
efficiency of your workers in the
production line basically optimization
is a hundred percent about being a cog
in the machine
and now it's a little bit of a
bit about us people especially as we are
facing automation where pretty much
anything where you're a cognitive
machine it's just a matter of time
before you just take another machine
because they're actually better at big
machines than we are so we are really
optimizing ourselves to irrelevance if
what you want is to be a better call in
the machine
and at that point maybe it's worth like
going hold on pause at this point okay
if the job is to absorb as much data as
possible crunch it as quickly as
possible
um and get to an answer
then probably AI does it quite well
um
but that's not really what we do as
humans we we actually have two cognitive
systems there is a rational one and then
there's the emotional one and the
rational is one that to some extent AI
can take over some of those jobs the
emotional one is actually key and it's
not about you know am I having an
emotional experience that is one aspect
of it but basic things like decision
making especially in the face of
ambiguity is actually down to your
emotional system that's um
groundbreaking researched by ganasio and
others about
um now 20 years ago
where people that do have damage that
inhibits their emotions from functioning
properly it's not that they make bad
decisions they make no decisions and in
fact this is what happens when you try
to incorporate AIC in the workings of a
corporation
or or government and so on you can
crunch the numbers
the crunching in the numbers give you
some other numbers but it doesn't
actually give you a decision the
decision making happens either in a
system external to what the AI plugs in
or somebody just gets the numbers and
then they make a decision and the two
things can be quite separate going on in
human understanding which is not
computational
that it's different from what a computer
does so okay when people call it
artificial intelligence I think that's a
misnomer
what should official cleverness perhaps
right but AC stands for you know
alternating current so you couldn't say
hey it wouldn't work
but
how many people would you say I know you
don't like sides in this but how many
agreements but the the fashion has run
against you the fashion is that no no
we're going to build a machine and and
human consciousness is essentially we
will be able to capture it in a digital
machine yeah well I think that's just
wrong
there you heard it here first no no I
mean you've been making
well you said I did something else more
recently I produced a chess position
you see which
you give it to Fritz tuned that's the
best chess computer system you see and
you programming to to be a Grand Master
Level and this is a chest position that
you show it to any human player who who
knows anything about the game at all
it's obviously a drawn game it's a draw
but
if you give it to Fritz and play against
Fritz it loses
really yeah and I was expecting it to
lose too you were a clever clogs aren't
you well
well not a chess that's that's my I was
the chest dancing my family
and how do people react to this that
must have upset about people immensely
well some people say oh I could I could
program my computer to do that but of
course that's cheating because you're
using your understanding to well I'm not
sure it wouldn't be quite hard to
I mean you can do it too I could probe
even I could
program a computer to do the right thing
in this position
but then you see changes a little bit
then I wouldn't you see yeah this
position you see that that's what I mean
he could program it to get the right
answer for that position sure but then
when you say there's something going on
in human consciousness which is
non-computation it's quite an innocent
sounding sentence really but what would
you what word would you reach for to
describe the thing which is not
computational would you reach for
something like Intuition or inspiration
understanding understanding yeah but an
understanding that you didn't get
through by steps of logic
yeah because even that's not
understanding you're just following the
rules
you see if you simply follow the rules
you've been given
you can do that without any
understanding the understanding is why
the rules work
and that's something different right and
that's why I say the girdle thing shows
you that if you know why these steps
will give you only truths if you've gone
through that that level of understanding
allows you to transcend
those rules themselves yes and that's
something that that girdle and you and
someone like Greg chaitany of all said
the computer
once you've given it the rules like the
rules that they put into Deep Mind or
the you know the the program that beat
Gary Kasper off it can
laboriously explore all permutations of
that rules but it can't jump outside the
rules and you're saying the human mind
you can
but not by having another rule that
steps behind it
to say of now and again jump out of
these rules because to then be trapped
in that larger set of rules you'd still
be trapped